well good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the long finance
conference here at the Willis corporate
headquarters my name is Duncan Holmes
and I have I'm the managing director of
our financial institutions and
professional risk practice here in
London we're delighted to host such a
thought pro-king visionary event
promoting long term sustainability in
finance the environment and social
responsibility here at Willis - we try
to take a long-term view and in building
this magnificent new headquarters we
were passionate to achieve the highest
level of sustainability rating we could
and I'm pleased to announce that we
indeed we did achieve an excellent
rating willis has 20,000 employees
worldwide spread over 400 offices in
about 119 countries advising clients how
to manage and transfer their risks to
hopefully give them some long-term
stability so you're not here to listen
to me so I would like to now hand over
to Professor Michael Minelli chairman of
zdn who will open today with a short
introduction to long finance entitled
long finance made from real money
ladies and gentlemen welcome to long
finance as we say in commerce to
business time is short
our program is long which is rather
ironic as we're talking about long
finance our financial system over a
period of say 75 to a hundred years the
long finance initiative began with a
conundrum when would we know our
financial system is working and I want
to spend a moment just retracing our
steps when Ian Harris and I founded C n
back in 1994 we started writing about
systemic weaknesses accounting
sustainability transparency credit
ratings the quiddity regulation you name
it and over the years we filled columns
for various journals such as the Journal
of risk finance and others over the past
five years some of you will realize I
filled 29 gresham lectures with things I
wanted to get off my chest my wife may
find that surprising is she probably
rather I got some things off
my stomach but but there you have it
along the way others joined in in 2005
young Peter instead er helped us
establish the London Accord for
environmental social and governance
research when the credit crunch broke in
2007 we wrote about the religion of
regulation and the wicked problems
involved in good financial markets our
key question has always been when would
we know our financial system is working
and in presentations around Europe and
the USA we posed this question to
audiences to clients to dinner
companions so when Bob Giffords
approached us about writing a book
analyzing the financial crisis we had a
lot of material to combine with his
thought-provoking ideas we termed the
current financial crisis credits crunch
in the firm conviction that much more is
at stake than just recovery from current
economic confusion scrunch means to
crush to crumple to squeeze and our
booklet analyzed the credits crunch as a
systemic failure with multiple causes
and multiple effects we believe that an
important discontinuity requires a
holistic rethink and response the
booklet is in your packs today and is
distributed free online and from all
this we decided to do something a
kitchen cabinet came together their
names are on the back of the flyer but
seeking a name for the project itself I
pondered something I'd heard about long
now a crazy attempt to build a clock
that bombed once every hundred years and
with the cuckoo coming out once every
thousand long now was looking at 10
millennia and I wondered if finance
could look forward just one lifetime we
contacted the long now folk and
instantly found immense support and
common ground anthropologist Claude
lévi-strauss concluded that the learned
man is not the man who provides the
correct responses rather he is the man
who poses the right questions and what
strikes me most about long now is the
impertinence of their questions now
systems haven't been working I once
wrote something threatens the entire
global financial system that is the
entire global financial system historian
Neil Ferguson concurs
he writes by the end of 2007 15 mega
banks with combined shareholder equity
of 857 billion had total assets of
thirteen point six trillion and
off-balance-sheet commitments of five
point eight trillion nineteen point
three trillion in total an aggregate
leverage ratio of 23 to one they had
also underwritten derivatives with a
gross national value of 216 trillion
more than a third of the total global
GDP is only 55 trillion and this was
controlled by an oligopoly of 15
investment banks for auditing firms and
3 credit rating agencies which reduced
diversity and encouraged herd behavior
but the 10 trillion of rescue money
spent so far has been spent on one
increasing the money supply to reducing
your motivation to save and 3
consolidating the banking sector further
now Mason Colley pointed out that the
question you're not supposed to ask is
the important one and it surprised us
that despite the biggest crash in our
lifetimes
we heard few good questions murmurs in
the hallway about when things might
return to normal now everyone has their
favorite fixes some of them
contradictory but the question we should
be asking far more stridently is when
would we know our financial system is
working in over the past two years we've
realized we're hardly alone at our last
long finance event nearly 40 people out
of the 120 who came were still debating
in Gresham's Court guard 90 minutes
after the event had finished but more
permanent solutions need these
impertinent questions such as when can
we fund a forest or when can a 20 year
old responsibly enter into a financial
arrangement or structure for their
retirement an average 20 year old today
should under reasonable actuarial
assumptions live to 95 most 20 year olds
with whom i chat assumed they lived to
at least 120 so the question implies a
financial structure that should last 70
five to a hundred years and such
questions raise a host of related issues
such questions draw in actuaries
accountants demographers insurers
bankers investment managers politicians
savers consumers and twenty-year-olds
and long finance is therefore meant to
be a collaborative vehicle dedicated to
renewing long term commerce from an
intellectual and systems perspective we
aim to improve society's understanding
and use of finance over the long term
we'd like to combine some of the long
now vision with intellectual rigour and
some of the community aspects of the
London Accord we definitely intend to
move commercial regulatory and
government thinking from responsive to
anticipate Ori and hopefully from local
to global current government thinking is
confused about reform it's incremental
at best and overly complex this slide
shared by Anthony Kirby of Ernst and
Young is an overview of just EU
initiatives and takes account neither
national nor international nor g20
reforms long fat finance hopes to avoid
the thickets of current micro reforms
taking the debate towards innovative
solutions now our iconic focus of long
finance comparable we think to the clock
of the long now
although hardly as big is the
paradoxical concept of enduring value
and thanks to neal stephenson's push for
us to do something physical what we call
the eternal coin the eternal coin is a
thought experiment that speculates on
whether a coin that never loses value
could exist and if such a coin could
exist how might it be constructed value
is of course intrinsically tied to
future exchange coals on future wealth
and the logos are based around a mobius
strip the coin you can't flip because it
has one side the coins motto is real
money made from eternal coins and
eternal coins made from real money of
course amoebas Strip is also without end
an endless conveyor belt of values from
the past to the future the eternal coin
project we hope will be explainable to
the man on this
and link the research we're designing an
online game where people can create
their own currencies and talk about what
enduring value means in a sustainable
financial system will it be combinations
of currencies bonds shares energy
forestry land water or carbon or burning
the tears Tara we're exploring mobile
applications so people can trade eternal
coins in a giant giant scenario planning
exercise and we're looking to create
pedagogical materials leading perhaps to
events rolling around the world back in
1990 David Hilbert assembled all the
mathematicians to set out a successful
roadmap for the 23 big math problems
that dominated the 20th century his
metamathematics road map resulted in
seventeen of the problems being solved
so far emulating David Hilbert
successful approach we'd like to host
him at a commerce discussion creating a
roadmap for commerce and finance
research we have also mapped out eight
themes for research based around a
traveling series of events as well as
reports and software each theme should
produce an eternal coin for example the
sustainability team might issue peak a
basket currency weighted by the
remaining life of key resources we're
seeking formal research funding for the
themes and I give you a sample here
ranging from studying the finances of
institutions of longevity for example
the Vatican or what can we learn from
economics and harsh climates the Bushman
the Inuit we want to challenge thinking
had long financed existed in 1900 when
David Hilbert was talking I hope it
would have challenged you with ideas
such as automotive insurance will be
commonplace in five decades why would
everyone need a car or in the future you
may be paying for shopping and meals
with bakelite how can plastic be used as
money we hope that some of the answers
that we're looking at might reveal
themselves but they may also be a boring
slog of regulatory reform or a
concession
perhaps that there are no answers some
answers might be revolutionary for
example we talked about direct personal
retirement cohorts you are chosen to
join an impartial a selected group of
six hundred people distributed around
the globe who under the management of a
central coordinator are responsible
directly for each other's retirement the
central coordinator directs your
retirement cohort to save and sets out
the long-term transfers of risk and
reward however unlike a pension fund
perhaps the central coordinator he or
she never controls your money quite
possibly held in some safe haven
governed by international law the cohort
in this case might be your most
important social network because it not
the state is responsible for your
financial security in retirement
we intend to investigate these types of
innovations peer to peer risk transfer
counter cyclical pricing government bond
cuffs our first two publications are in
your packs today and free online an
eternal brevity where Malcolm Cooper
looks at history using eternal coins and
to finance short where David Stephen
takes a long finance view of the
contemporary mortgage market money is a
medium of exchange exchanges values
across time and space and it cuts to the
heart of what our society values an
equitable Society requires fair exchange
globally and with future generations a
sustainable society requires us to
treasure scarce resources in an
increasingly crowded planet if you don't
value it
you won't sustain it so when you think
about it we have to be able to exchange
in trust with the global community
present and future and anglo-saxon
models aren't the entire answer the
German ambassador was here in the
audience today once pointed out to me
that despite two world wars and two
economic collapses his grandfather's
pension was
paid our eternal coin thought-experiment
forces us to contrast our values with
those of our great great grandchildren's
and this leads to my Zen koan if you
have some trust I shall give you trust
if you have no trust I shall take it
away from you so why today well today's
objectives are simple one the long now
people are here to inspire us the
projects like theirs can make a
difference and I welcome them too you
may be inspired by long finance to ask
impertinent questions and three we want
to engage you with a different event
that adds hope and humor to some serious
subjects time is too pressing for open
discussion among 400 people though many
of you pre submitted questions that will
come up in the panels
I do hope long finance links you with
others inspired to think about renewing
our commerce with each other once you
look through the lens of long finance
you realize that many of today's
sustainability issues arise because
society's core risk reward transfer
system finance isn't yet capable of
handling long term commerce and I'm
betting it's worth founding along
finance Institute to develop these new
approaches or you can collect from me
and OH - oh seven eight when I'm 120
thank you
thank you and now you must open your hem
books
towards the back to the page marked my
fund man for those of you without him
books please look inside your program
and I'd suggest you warm up your vocal
cords as brother Ian Harris shall lead
us through our first interlude brother
Harris there are two very good reasons
why you should exercise your vocal cords
on on this song
in fact there's there's one very good
reason there's there's one quite poor
reason we do have Brian Eno here and all
that those of you who you know still
harbor those you know those thoughts of
you know maybe I'll be spotted one day
well Bryant Browns gonna be listening
with the rest of you that's the bad
reason the good reason is as you can see
I'm miked up and I'm going to be singing
so unless plenty of you join in with me
you will have to hear me singing this
and that's really not what you want now
I know a little bit about Finance I know
a little bit more about words I don't
know very much about music but I believe
that this one is in the key of my my
right my kid mic so without further ado
I'm going to try to do a bouncing ball
with this thing is that what yes so
without further ado maestro
here we go my fund man said borrow and
plan
so don't Fred when you run up some debt
off went me house to a mortgage tracker
in went the cash to an equity NACA
which deal it then rallied rallied then
diligence way on Sanctus like a stone
oh you can't trust the bankers they're a
load of thankless focu repossess my home
thank you very much editor of Channel 4
News
you don't hid from me we've got the
whole long now executive team here we're
going to talk about its origins what
they're doing now and as befits the
concept future of a long now foundation
so I like to invite Brian you know I
don't think he needs much introduction
to begin with the origins of long now
thanks Brian scale of things makes a
difference to how they operate
Aristotle's example was that if you
scale a mouse up its legs aren't strong
enough you have to you have to scale the
legs up much more than you scale the
height I had also started to notice that
the same thing was true of time that
duration actually made a difference not
only a degree but of kind and I had
noticed that societies that thought in
terms of weeks and months tended to
think differently than societies that
thought in terms of years and decades
now in 1978 I moved to New York
a very fast and at that time quite
dangerous and pretty dysfunctional City
and I noticed that everybody there was
passing through actually there were very
few people who felt that they were New
Yorkers who lived in New York they were
people who are on their way to somewhere
else and so there was an attitude of
being in the city for a short term using
the city as a springboard to move on to
something else what that meant was that
there was a very dysfunctional civil
society things didn't work very well the
city was falling apart and in fact
during that time I think went bankrupt
at one point I I came up with this idea
that there was something called the
short now and New York was was living in
the short now in the sense that if you
said to somebody I would meet artists
and I'd say what are you working on and
they would tell me what they were
working on that week not what their life
project was or even their project for
this year was but what they were doing
that week or even that day and it seemed
that their horizons their time horizons
were very very short this made for a
very exciting city because things were
constantly changing it was like living
in a fashion store but it didn't make
for a very functioning smooth-running
City so having come up with the idea of
that everybody there was living in the
short now I posed the opposite idea
which was the thought that the societies
that I might prefer to live in were long
now societies and in fact subsequently I
met Stewart and prepare yes others
discovered that they were thinking along
that pretty much the same lines Peter
Schwartz one of our co-founders was at
that time working on a book called the
long view which was a book about
business trying to think of business in
the long term Stewart had been working
for many years on projects that had very
long-term ramifications and so we came
together for this project which
eventually took the name the long knife
and
we've only got a short time here so I'm
now going to hand over to Alexander who
who's the director of the long now
foundation he'll tell you something
about what we do
the projects of the long now foundation
really started with an idea by Danny
Hillis who's a computer scientist who
had this idea of a monument scale all
mechanical 10,000 year clock a physical
artifact that if you went to visit it in
fact they'd the going to visit it you
would have different conversations about
time and about your place in it then you
would if this was not a physical
artifact and I think this is very much
along the lines of what Neil Stevenson
was talking about with making this
eternal coin idea a physical thing that
the physical objects have a very
different ability to change conversation
where if we just have we only had
conferences the ideas would be fleeting
but if we go ahead and build the
physical object that it could be much
longer lasting and that if you if you
take these design principles that Danny
Hillis started with longevity
maintainability transparency
evolvability and scalability these are
all the things that we started measuring
all clock designs against but it is also
an interesting set of criteria to
measure anything against the eternal
coin any financial instrument that you
might be investing in back in 1999 I'm
just going to do a quick tour the the
geeky engineers version of what we're
working on in very physical objects or
initially this was the first prototype
of the clock this is actually housed
here in London at the Science Museum
it's at the at the end of the making of
the modern world exhibit and I'll just
talk very quickly one of the engineering
problems that we had to solve when
designing a clock that had to last
10,000 years that how do we keep the
clock synchronized to a now point and
that we chose to use the Sun so every
time the Sun anytime it's a sunny day at
noon we focus light through a lens it
heats up a piece of metal that piece of
metal expands we get a mechanical
trigger so now you have a clock that
keeps solar time now the problem with
that is that what we keep with pendulums
is called absolute time which doesn't
vary based on where the earth is in its
orbit this is the analemma it's also
very similar to the mobius strip I
notice
this is the Sun at the same time of day
taken throughout the year and so this
constitutes a problem that we had of
rectifying solar time - absolute time
the solution to that problem Danny
Hillis came up with which is this
physical shape so this is that equation
as it evolves for 10,000 years that
equation of plus or minus 15 minutes
that rectifies that analemma to a
straight line of noon is changing very
slightly as the earth wobbles on its
axis every 26,000 years and the earth
slows its rotational rate by about a
second a century and of course the other
innovation that we had to do was the
extra zero in front of the Gregorian
year date for a five year or a
five-digit date since then we've been
working on larger prototypes this is an
orrery shows the currently or the human
eye visible planets and this shows
mercury out through Saturn and as the
part of the clock that would allow
someone who doesn't understand our
kolender ik stool oook at the sky look
at our clock and understand what exactly
this thing might do even if it was not
working we've also purchased the site
for the monument scale version we
purchased this mountain in Eastern
Nevada
it's called Mount Washington it's about
as far as you can get from civilization
in North America it's a five hour drive
to any major airport it's one of the
darkest sky places in North America
pretty amazing sky viewing it also has
this amazing trait of not only very
competent rock that we can put the clock
into the idea is to build the clock
underground where it can last very long
but it also is populated by the oldest
living organisms in the world the
Bristlecone pine some of these trees
have been dated to forty eight hundred
years old and so they themselves are our
type of clock we have scientists who do
core drilling of of these and can tell
us the climate and how many years that
there was no sunshine for instance on
that one site over the last ten thousand
years by comparing dead and live tree
rings right now we're actually designing
the machines to build the underground
space we're combining the tech the
diamond saw technology that's now being
used in Carrara Italy
for querying marble with some of the
mining technology that that was being
developed in Sudbury Canada this is a
prototype this is actually the actual
saw it's a 9-foot reach diamond tooth
robotic chainsaw so we've roboticized a
saw to allow us to carve
three-dimensional underground spaces
that can be strong enough to handle the
seismic issues of Eastern Nevada this
saw has a nine foot blade and a 32 foot
region allow us to carve spiral
underground staircases the so as you can
see when when you do start to solve
problems very physically you have to
think about these things very
differently what are the hands of the
people going to be like that might wind
this clock are they going to have you
know if you're building a spiral
staircase are you going to build a
spiral staircase that has the same foot
pitch that we now consider to be a
normal foot pitch if you've ever been on
the Mayan pyramids you'll you quickly
realize that they had a very different
idea of what a step was than we do the
last couple projects that I'm talking
I'll talk about our information based
projects also it back in 1999 we started
a project called the Rosetta project and
we had thought probably naively that we
could just collect all the world's
languages in one place they were
probably already digitized probably
already online and then we would micro
etch them into a medium that could last
for 10,000 years and it turned out of
course that nobody had ever put all that
information together anywhere so it
began a ten-year effort that our
nine-year effort we just finished it
this year but we have over 1500
languages micro etched on this disk this
is the that's 13,000 pages micro edged
and we collected things like the first
three chapters of the Bible which is
where the most trying translated things
in the world as well as maps
and basic information about all the
languages that we could find and that's
what those pages start to look like
close up and the last project that I'll
talk about is long bets this was this
was came out of one of Stewart brands
ideas for a responsibility roster and
the idea is that if people you know
often at conferences like this will make
a prediction about what the future will
be like and they're very rarely held
accountable for it and one of the best
ways to make those those bets very real
of course is to attach money to them
just this year Warren Buffett bet
protege partners over a 10-year period
commencing in January 1st 2008 and
ending in 2017 that the S&P 500 will
outperform a portfolio of hedge funds so
far we've just got the first update on
the first year of that and right now the
the hedge funds are actually winning
amazingly over the last over the last
year but they've got a million dollars
we have we have probably about 80 or 90
bets and about 150 different predictions
that are waiting for others the other
side to to take those bets and we plan
on keeping these around long enough that
not only can we say who won and who lost
but we can also take a look at these
detailed arguments and see if the way
people were thinking about the future
the arguments that they made it in fact
is there something extractable out of
that that we can learn from the that
will teach us how to think about our
futures better and I'll leave you with
this one economic example of 10,000 year
thinking I was trying to think actually
on the plane over here is there a real
10,000 year economic example and and I
was reminded of the mess lot barrier and
this is the the barrier and in Holland
it was designed for a once in a 10,000
year event no one's after actually seen
the storm that this thing is possibly
designed for the cost of building this
is over 600 million euros that's very
very expensive infrastructure right
Hurricane Katrina was a
once-in-a-century event killed over
1,800 people and it's currently costing
the United States 110 billion dollars so
you basically get a hundred times
leverage for thinking on these
timescales that the that the Dutch are
thinking by simply thinking a little bit
ahead you you do have to fund that
infrastructure which is very difficult
to do when things are all going just
fine but the day that that storm arrives
everyone wished she did
thank you well we were just getting this
going in the 1990s Danny Hillis and I
reconnected with Brian we hired
Alexander who was then very young and we
all I had a son named Noah who reads
even more science fiction than I do he
was in his teens at that time and he
said do you know about Robert Heinlein
oh come on I grew up on Robert Heinlein
do you know about a book by Robert
Heinlein called time for the Stars I'm
not sure I remember that one well I see
why it was written in 1956 and it's his
only kind of grim novel at the downer
but the reason Noah told me about the
book I'll just read a few passages is
the idea is these are the first
interstellar astronauts are shaping up
to go to the Stars time for the stars
and but the reason is happening is
there's this thing called we got
interested in the purposes of the
long-range foundation its coat of arms
reads Brad cast upon the waters as
charter has headed dedicated to the
welfare of our descendants the Charter
goes on with a lot of lawyers fog but
the way the directors have interpreted
it is it has to spend money only on
things that no government and no other
corporation would touch it wasn't enough
for a proposed project to be interesting
to science and socially desirable it
also had to be so horribly expensive
that no one else would touch it the
perspective results had to lie so far in
the future that it could not be
justified to taxpayer
or shareholders to make the lrf
directors light up with enthusiam you
had to suggest something that cost a
billion or more mmm that was back in the
day when it meant something and probably
wouldn't show results for 10 generations
if ever something like how to control
the weather they're working on that the
funny thing is that the bread cast upon
the waters does come back 700 full the
most preposterous projects made the lrf
embarrassing amounts of money
embarrassing to a nonprofit corporation
that is take space travel it seemed
tailor-made back a couple of hundred
years ago for lrf since it was
fantastically expensive and offered no
probable results comparable with the
investments the long range foundation
stepped in after military and everybody
else gave up and he happily began
wasting money it came at a time when the
corporation unfortunately made a few
billion on the Thompson mask of Georgia
which when they had expected to spend at
least a century on pure research since
they could not declare a dividend no
stockholders they had to get rid of the
money somehow and space travel looked
like a swell raffle to pour it down even
the kids know what happened to that
Ortega's torch made space travel easy
inside the solar system and fast and
cheap and the one-way energy screen made
colonization practicable and profitable
the long-range foundation could not
unload fast enough to keep from making
lots more money so this the long-range
foundation Brian came up with the idea
the long now all seemed to kind of blend
in and frankly the idea of a long bank
has been percolating in the background
for a while so we're interested in
what's coming arrived at here I'm mainly
in England now flogging a book called
whole earth discipline and the the
connection here is I'm puzzled by the
economics the theory of infrastructure
civilization cities all these important
things really really depend on sewer
systems that work what you were saying
about New York is the case what the
lowlands there below basically sea level
especially increasingly require a
serious infrastructure to keep going but
I have not been able to find
a really good economic theory of
infrastructure basically it's been cut
and try for centuries and people come up
with these the reality is we come up
with these grand schemes financial
excuses are made bonds are passed and
everything goes forward the finances
don't work out anything like what people
planned if their initial investors they
lose money and then somebody else buys
into it and the sunk costs are ignored
and they move ahead then we see with
wind farms we see with nuclear basically
it's the third owner it gets to make
money but we build these things anyway
so that's pretty interesting I would
love to see a real theory economic
theory of infrastructure go forward not
only for the build infrastructure
because you look at the bridges over the
Thames mmm they make London in a sense
possible it is a river straddling city
but the Thames itself is infrastructure
so the bridge is infrastructure the
river is infrastructure there's a lot of
natural infrastructure that can be
thought of and can be funded and can be
maintained the same way we think about
built infrastructure and we're just now
realizing that these so-called ecosystem
services you blow them up to the large
scale in the long term climate is one of
them a stable climate is all that
civilization is known for the last
10,000 years basically we had the
stability to make agriculture go forward
make cities go forward and civilization
was able to invent itself in this good
large-scale long-term weather that we've
had we're now really realizing a
byproduct of all that success of ours is
that we may be messing with the
healthiness of the ecosystem the weather
very complex system that we require in
order to function and so we're having to
step up to an infrastructural
relationship to the atmosphere the
climate of the whole damn planet this is
a larger scale issue than the Thames or
London or England or the global North
you know five out of six people live in
developing countries they are busily
getting out of poverty in building
cities faster than anybody ever has all
the rest of it so that
scale of the issues we're now dealing
with I think require comfort with
thinking long term which is all long now
is about is making people
ideally comfortable thinking in multi
hundred multi-thousand year terms and
please we would like some long finance
to do all this with not to talk about I
mean I'm a TV reporter I'm pretty used
to working on a very short term basis
the finances here have been acutely
working on the rather short-term basis
what is the essence of the ten thousand
year horizon is it totemic I mean are
you just happy to get people to arrive
time horizons out you know just fifty or
hundred years why ten thousand years the
number came from Peter Schwartz one of
our founding directors and was here for
a long time
Royal Dutch Shell Helix scenario
planning there and did this book called
the art of the long view and Peter said
civilization sort of started with towns
and agriculture that happened basically
10,000 years ago the ice retreated in
the northern hemisphere at that time
it's a kind of a start point and if you
assume and you come to a scientific idea
which is that it's always helpful to
assume that whatever you're looking at
you're sort of in the normative you're
in the middle of it and so if
civilization has lasted ten thousand
years so far you assume were in the
middle of that story then the next
10,000 years
fills out the symmetry Brian came up
with the term the longer now so for us
long now is the current twenty thousand
years and the idea is to just as we
think of last week and next week is sort
of the operative now that we work in you
know can you think about the last ten
thousand years the way you think about
last week and can you think about the
next ten thousand years the way you
think about next week and if we can
accomplish that then then we start
waving our hands faster you seem good
things will happen
Brian when you put these sorts of ideas
out there do you get the response are
you expecting the response from the sort
of average persons street to sort of
care about the utility of somebody in 50
a hundred five hundred thousand ten
thousand years time as much as they care
about somebody right now
well back to a point that Alexander made
that the physicality of something makes
a very big difference to it if it's just
a thought experiment it's it's forgotten
as a thought experiment could be but the
fact that we've actually started making
these clocks we're currently building
one in Texas we've got a prototype in
the science museum here the fact that
they have actually started to take
physical reality has really made people
interested in them in a different way so
people start to think about the design
problems they say but how can you
possibly know that there won't be
another Dark Ages in the next thousand
years for example and we say well of
course we can't but just the fact of
people engaging their mind in that way
to think a thousand years in the future
is already even at the sketchiest level
it's far beyond what any of us ever
normally think so so the fact of this
thing coming into existence and being
more than just a metaphor it makes a big
difference I think people do start to
think about it but we haven't we have a
culture do we not that's incredibly fast
and gotta be disposable it's in many
ways the very opposite of some of the
stuff that we've just been talking about
well really the seed of this as the seed
of the clock really came from Danny
Hillis who was who had time just built
the world's fastest computer and he was
very aware of how finely we're slicing
time up now you know we're talking in
much much faster periods of time than
nanoseconds and he was aware that our
horizons were we were intensely
interested in them in the very near
future and correspondingly disinterested
in the far future I mean we have a we
have a sort of long now parable that we
tell which I
I think is a true story new college in
Oxford
being English of course it's not that
new it was built I think in 1480 and in
the 1960s the great big beams across the
top of new college big oak beams they're
enormous they're that big started to
decay and so the college purser went to
the head woodsman because Oxford owns a
lot of land all over England it went to
the head woodsman and said do you think
anywhere that we have wood to replace
these beams and the woodsman said well
yes sir funny you should ask and it
turned out that when the college was
built they had planted another grove of
Oaks to replace the beams so those Oaks
had been quietly growing for five
hundred years and in fact they they are
now the new beams in New College Oxford
so it's it's interesting another set of
they planted some new ones but but it's
interesting that we as humans now are at
the very peak of our power we've never
been more powerful you know any one of
us is as powerful as half an army was a
thousand years ago we've never been more
powerful but we've never been less
responsible about future events we we
tend not to think in those very long
terms like five hundred years or even 25
years actually it's quite ironic you
think okay let me close out Xander when
I travel around doing economic reports
all around the world and I maybe you're
going to think I'm making conceptual
mistake here but the people planning for
the next decades appeared to be the
people are less democratic is there a
structural issue that well I think that
you do see worldwide there isn't
interesting there's an interesting thing
that happens if you if you're going to
rule a country for your whole life as a
monarch for instance you are you do
think longer term than a democratically
elected system
and you know England with its dual
systems I think has get some of that it
was just I think Brian just just sent me
a set of photographs of the current
Queen with all the presidents since was
it eisenhower yes and of the United
States and you realize that you know
where else do you see that kind of
consistency except in a in a monarchy
and and you know that's kind of fallen
from rule to more ceremonial role but
they even that ceremonial role has a
consistency that you don't see in normal
democratic systems which are are by
definition a churning system and they
they they fit well with the capitalist
systems that have also driven our our
financial problems with that kind of
churn as well in the growth phase but
they don't fit well when you have
something that looms over 80 or 90 years
like the like the the property values
dropping only once in 90 years how does
that how can a politician who's elected
for four years plan for around the
property values which everything is
leveraged on falling in at some
indeterminant point in their future they
just can't so it's I think in Germany
there was a move to alter the
Constitution to account for the future
rights of future generations I don't I
don't know where that went I didn't
quite keep a track of that perhaps in
battle details later but um do you think
that the normal churning of democracy
every four five ten years there'd be
some way to kind of take account of
longer term generational equity not just
over 20 40 years but over hundreds of
years well and it's so far the answer is
no I mean we don't I can't think of any
good exams to it and you likewise with
finance you know the problem of
discounting the future that you've
raised the question earlier of how do
you fund to forest and you know putting
money in a forest where you get returned
basically in 70 years time versus
putting the same amount of money in the
bank where you get the same amount of
return and a lot shorter than 70 years
you know what just happened doesn't make
sense so every now and then somebody
liquidates a forest company came named
maxim likes name came into Northern
California bought up a nice old family
firm that was logging redwoods
sustainably in Northern California and
cut all the damn things down because it
made economic sense to do that and you
know I know environmentalists and
economists and so on have been trying to
figure out how do you blend in the
externalities and all the rest of this
um I don't think we've solved the
problem of discounting the future yeah
in finance just as I don't think we've
solved the problem of long-term
responsibility in democracies yeah so
one place you might look for some sorts
of solutions to this are they are the
most long-term businesses we know that
there are religions basically the
interesting thing about religions is
that they they offer other rewards than
financial ones I happen not to believe
in them myself but I'm starting to think
I should encourage other people too
mostly people that's because yeah I
believe in gospel singing yeah that's a
long story do you think that this
mindset is consistent with being free
market ear can this be achieved through
the market well have free is free
because none of us are really free
marketeers you will notice that even in
countries that such as America that
claim to be free market there are for
instance restrictions on monopolies that
there are always restrictions nobody
actually really wants a free market
because it's utterly chaotic and you're
just as likely to get slaughtered
whatever position you are in the free
market so so I question that phrase what
what you're really talking about is on
the long spectrum between total control
and total freedom where do you want to
situate yourself and that's that's all
that happens in capitalist countries
they they argue about which position
along the line they are it's not about
free or unfree it's about where on the
Speck
from you up okay industry alright so
he'll keep coming back the physicality
and the eternal coin paper that is in
everybody's lap I thought the most
telling thing in and when you're looking
at sort of what worth what sustained
value at various times in human history
and one that jumped out at me was land
which sort of maps onto something I've
noticed which is even longer in life
than religions is some cities Jericho
has been a town for ten thousand years
Jerusalem has changed religion thirty
six times and been captured and burned
and all this kind of stuff in this film
it was an important city five thousand
years ago and it is now so cities have
this capability this enormous longevity
and enormous adaptability but a
peculiarity of cities is that they are
actually quite physical there's a place
that is the only the land is the real
estate value and so three things I now
want is I want theory of infrastructure
please economic theory I want an
economic theory of the informal economy
which is sustaining most of the
developing world and where people are
getting the hell out of complete poverty
into toward participating in the global
economy and I would like a theory of
real estate that would reflect basically
the entire history of real estate
there's probably two thousand histories
of architecture all of which are
frivolous there's not a single history
of real estate which would tell us why
these cities have this longevity in some
cases why some are really longer with
than others in the rest of it
and for all I knew the fundamental coin
of living on a planet may well be
expressible in land terms in real estate
terms and that's what we should conjure
around let me bring in something very
kind of recent where the world was
invited to think about the long-term
consequences of their actions and share
out the burden and I didn't seem to work
out were talking about Copenhagen do it
doesn't seem when the world has been
invited that they play ball with the
idea of looking after future generations
and sharing that burden equitably across
see would you be depressed by that type
of thing well I think it fits into the
category that that Brian said is that
you know it just depends on what system
you invite everyone in to play and and
in in Copenhagen they they invite 192
countries each one with veto power like
there's no system in the world that
could function that way and so it's set
up for failure if you set the rules for
failure you're going to fail so the you
know currently our capitalist systems
are set for a very short term return you
know just as as Stuart's been pointing
out in his recent book that until you
make call expense it more expensive than
carbon free alternatives you every
country is going to burn their coal till
it's gone and so there's there's there's
no way around that so you do have to set
rules and you just have to pick and
choose what those rules are and so I
think it comes down to game theory and
and how you're going to do it yeah I
mean they don't even they can't even
agree on sharing the benefits of trade
it doesn't seem particularly likely that
you'd agree on sharing the economic
short-term economic dis benefits of
taking making sacrifices for future
generations does this require basically
stronger international coordination
stronger international government
governance is basically my expectation
is if climate keeps scaring it shows
signs are doing that we don't get ahead
of mitigation of cutting back on
greenhouse gases in time that we will
take geoengineering seriously direct
intervention in the climate and
climatologists have seen some accessible
examples of that of you know volcano
goes up in the Philippines in 1991 in
the next year you've got a lot more
polar bear cubs because the whole planet
cooled down by half degrees Celsius okay
so that works and so they're now half a
dozen going on to a dozen good projects
of how you might cool the earth directly
just by going at climate that's the easy
problem the hard problem is the
political one
because you know one of the scheme is is
you could actually keep the planet cool
while we double our carbon dioxide for
an expensive making 300 million a year
that's nothing
there are wealthy people probably some
in this room we could just do that China
could certainly just do that and China
may well have feel reason to they're
having serious droughts in the northwest
they're getting sea level problems and
extreme weather problems on the south
coast and they can say well really just
put a bunch of sulphur dust in the
stratosphere and fix that little problem
well all the rest of us live downwind of
China which is everybody would say
actually that's an act of war so because
we don't un is not going to step up the
market it's not going to step up to that
the current international relations that
we have are not yet in place to work out
the norms and the agreements and the
transparencies and all the rest of it to
where you can start doing geoengineering
this various ways my expectation is I
think Brian loves this and you're
probably curious or word of it is that
more increments of global governance
will emerge from the climate issues that
we'll be dealing with over the next
basically over the century is that your
view Brian yeah
well people are terrified some of them
by the idea of global governments
especially English people actually
unless they're in charge shows we have a
whole political party organized to
prevent that the exactly yeah so but as
I always point out to them we have been
living with many many examples of it for
a long time for instance none of us as
far as I know are complaining about the
International Postal Union which was
formed in 1879 and which is one of the
most successful forms of global
cooperation ever every country in the
world belongs to it and it's it's a very
sophisticated mechanism that ensures
that if you post a letter in Birmingham
it gets delivered in Kabul or wherever
you know and all you know about is that
you bought a stamp it's an amazing
system and we've all been doing it for
years it's a form of all these
complicated reciprocal agreements
between
a hundred and sixty-five countries I
think belong to its it's a form of
governance you know we're quite happy
with it
we don't complain about it and there
there are many other examples that some
of them are really very obscure like
there is an international agreement for
the genetic labeling of mice which which
has 59 countries subscribe to it have
you never labeled them
we've got about a minute and oh sorry
this is not good maybe longfin ant but
we're going to be very tight on time I'm
gonna I want 30 seconds from each of you
at the eternal clock existed before
Europe industrialized how would the
world be different now well it's always
been our fantasy that if we if we choose
exactly the right mountain in exactly
the right place that if we dig into it
will actually find the clock already
there so what would how would our world
be different if we if we were to all of
a sudden find it or if it we were it up
to always have had and so I mean
curiously the person who connected our
two foundations neal stephenson played
this out in a science fiction book of
another world that was ruled by both a
very fast civilization of mini-malls and
cellphones and a very slow civilization
of academics and thinkers that were
thinking through the world's long-term
problems and it's it's nearly a thousand
pages long so i we probably shouldn't
get into it there but i'll just plug
that as you're as a way to possibly look
at that kind of theme and event focus
Anitha it's first-rate the goal the long
now foundation is below we've succeeded
when long-term thinking is automatic and
common instead of difficult and rare
thanks to prime last word
goodbye I'm trying to answer your
question we in a sense we do have some
examples as I said about religions we do
have some examples of of icons that have
lasted for a very long time
my problem with religions is that I
think they haven't generally inspired
people to exactly the kind of behavior
that I would like to see but I do think
we can take some strength from the fact
that certain images and metaphors exist
for very very long periods all sorts of
civilizational change can happen and
they can stay in place and so I think
we're hoping that this would be one of
those great well thank you so much for
coming here and of course
[Applause]